In this case study, we're going
to go into maybe excruciating
detail showing you how
I really am not always
sure about which point of
view I'm going to be taking.
With these microneedles I
just placed them on my table,
just to take a look
at it to kind of get
a sense of what they look like.
I even went further and put
them on top of the Petri dish,
which they came in, just
to sort of study it.
I actually don't mind this
image as a final image.
I was surprised.
But as you've seen
before, you've
seen the microneedles placed
on the flatbed scanner, which
does produce a really
wonderful image.
I then decided to
also then go back
and refine the arrangement.
There are two colors
that the researchers
decided to distinguish between,
showing pink and clear.
Just looking at the
depth of field...
Here I'm starting to
compose for a cover shot.
In this image, I did the same
thing thinking about a cover,
but just using one color.
I thought that the
pink was distracting.
In this next image, I just
refined the color a bit,
which we could do in software.
In this image, I'm still
looking at a point of view.
Look carefully as I slightly
change the positioning
of the disk in the lower left.
Watch as I go back to
what I previously had,
and just very ever
so slightly change it
so that it doesn't
become redundant
with the other arrangements.
These are very,
very minute changes,
But this is sort of what
you have to go through.
In the end, the
interesting thing
was that the researcher
sent me a very wonderful
microscopic picture
of these microneedles,
and he really wanted
to try to get a cover.
And although this course is
about a camera and a lens,
I thought it would
be interesting
for you to see the possibility
of creating a potential cover
submission from a
horizontal picture.
I really do encourage
you to consider
doing these kinds of things.
We're not changing
the microneedles.
We're just changing the
background of the microneedles.
And so from this initial shot,
we in fact did get the cover.